I have changed my outfit and accessories
so many times to find something suitable
to wear for this video and I've ended up
wearing a wrinkled shirt with a stain on
the collar hello my name is Grace all
but if you didn't know now you know your
life is different now subscribe just
gonna shame lessly throw that out there
well shame there's shame there is shame
there's a lot of shame ain't no no shame
in this game South Pickett please the
Met Gala happened on Monday there are so
close and if you do not know what the
Met Gala is you're in the majority it's
an event that happens once a year at the
Met in New York City and it is meant to
honor fashion question mark it's
basically just a parade of fashion 3
which calls for a red carpet fashion
review for me
sloppy friend you sometimes worry about
whether she's doing alright
every year the Met Gala has a theme to
it last year was China question mark
this year the theme is manas amok in a
fashion in the age of technology all of
the attendees of the Met Gala are free
to interpret that theme on their body as
they choose here's my interpretation
fashion in the age of technology I am
NOT a robot I am human let's get into
this Beyonce o start now very easy
Beyonce it looks like a naked Barbie
doll like a naked rubber Barbie doll
like a naked rubber Victorian 80s Barbie
doll how so kinda looks like a baby's
Victorian dildo a very beautiful rubber
shiny Victorian eighties dildo here's
another angle whoa I'm adding some Fiona
gear in that but because that would be
very wrong team cute nicki minaj why
cinch your waist with the belt when you
can send your whole body it feels very
S&M pilgrim I get it Kristen Stewart you
know like those outdoor rugs that they
make with like the black bristles after
a hard day's work you can like stomp out
your combat boots you like that cute I
was a big fan of that hair girl I'm
rooting for you so lunch is a very
secure woman that does not need the
spotlight no offense but this looks kind
of like the JV version of bouncer
this looks like those you know crepe
paper circular decorations for like
graduation parties and stuff very DIY
Solange Alexa Chung Bob everything looks
with Chung wares and I love this yeah
she might be preparing for a flood but
fashion in the age of technology you
don't want to get your metal jumpsuit
wet it will rest she is smart
Emma Stone what the Wow you look like a
Grecian sex doll and me and beautiful
okay Barry why the knot this is what I
like to see the Met Gala is about
nonsense this is you are you Jared Leto
though or are you Katy Perry this might
be Jared Leto this is Jared Leto so
that's Jared Leto as Giga Perry this is
the most fashion-forward Face Swap I've
ever seen Kim Kardashian and Kanye West
this is okay yeah I actually really like
Kim's dress a lot Kanye looks a little
bit like flamboyant rodeo dad and the
contacts when I can look like a robot I
think I'm malfunctioning cute maybe
Madonna Siri what's happening with
Madonna's kids like I'm looking at like
HTML coding right now like this is AI a
lot to look at but when in doubt tits
out Lady gaga yeah yes yeah and also yes
I'm into this I read online that her
corset is actually made out of like
circuit breaker or circuit board or
could something Circuit City circuit
boards her leotard is made out of
circuit board Gaga loves a good theme
and that's why we all love Gaga so I'm
pretty sure her look is trying to
manifest I Wi-Fi which is just like
wildly unsteady Kate Hudson looks like
that looks like a very DIY sexy
stormtrooper but my favorite accessory
of this whole look is you look that Lady
Gaga has giving her the background like
really also is anyone else seeing a
demonic young girl's face in the dress
right in the cooter area okay let's move
on
zoe saldana Wow okay this looks a little
bit like she took the entire artificial
fly
our section of Michael's and made a
skirt out of it very pinterest he might
have also heard a bunch of peacocks also
that shot directly in the butt by a
confetti cannon on the way over to Linda
Gomez looks like a homeschooled child
that has never had the Internet and this
is what she thinks
sexy dressing is like very on theme Rita
Ora she murdered so many robot geese for
this Patrick Taylor Swift okay well okay
this looks mm-hmm feels a little bit
like you and Selena had the same theme
we put you Breanna and guy right next to
each other we'd have some future version
of your choice
Emma Watson you I'm literally just
drooled and spit all over my mouth do
you see this I literally just
malfunctioned looking at a photo box I
gotta move on Sienna Miller or Naomi
Watts we could do some facial
recognition one of you is one of you and
the other of you is the other a fashion
in the age of technology oh my god oh my
god you both look right Anna Kendrick I
mean the net I get it be my friend Gigi
Hadid and Zayn Malik saying your names
makes me feel like I'm a voice on google
translate feel like getting through
airport security named Malik more like
Zayn metallic Gigi Hadid more like Gigi
had died in your arms tonight because
when you tried to hug her your metal
arms accidentally stabbed her Dakotah
that girl you look like a scarf or the
magician pulls out of this mouth of a
children's magic show then day after
head kind of looks like a dick tip which
is appropriate because that dress is
given me a boat Oh Lord is that you I am
trying to be cute robot Lupita I'm into
this this is like Cindy Lou Who dot-com
software upgrades oh the Olsons are
there thank God
fashion the age of technology I think
they're both still running a dial-up
modem right now Jaden and Willow Smith
you guys are just the Internet
personified so you could show up like
anything and it would be on theme this
year
Jimmy Lovato Wow it was a little bit
like you took like an 80s windbreaker
and then I cut it open and it approached
glitter and then got really angry about
it and stood in front of a bunch of
people with cameras cute there Jessica
Parker a lion and a witch in the
wardrobe and this is what happened
that's it that is my red carpet review
of the Met Gala hopefully this was
enjoyable on any level let me know who
you thought looked great who you thought
looked and don't forget to subscribe
thanks for watching I don't know oh
there's Jared Leto but is that Katy
Perry